Wall Street Journal story after visiting
an Israeli Community attack by Hamas
stated those intent on murder must be
neutralized he expressed concerns about
the propaganda promoting violence saying
the propaganda must stop that is
training people to be murderers in the
future during his visit to Israel musk
remarked it was jarring to see the scene
of the massacre while discussing the
attacks on Israel civilians he
emphasized the need to make Gaza more
prosperous for lasting peace saying I
would love to help Israel's
communication minister Glo Kari
announced an agreement in principle had
been reached with musk regarding the use
of starlink uh uh satellite units
highlighting the importance of
controlling technology in the conflict
with Hamas well it's interesting because
uh musk after basically taking a lot of
heat over some certain anti-semitic
rhetoric which I think was overblown
anyway uh went to go see the atrocities
after what happened in October 7th and
he actually met with um BB Netanyahu and
Isaac Herzog the president of Israel and
uh he basically gave a three-pronged
approach I this is not any situation
that could be oversimplified but here
was Elon Musk approach what could be
done with Gaza um and I actually fully
agree with it it's number one you need
to destroy Hamas so anyone that doesn't
uh understand that this is Isis this is
al- Qaeda this is El nusra this is bah
Haram they are we talked about having uh
a belief in a higher power power but
there's
extremists that basically believe that
they are Divine from God jihadists that
basically it's their way or the highway
and there's no negotiating with these
people they believe in this there's no
way of getting away from that now
there's a whole separate conversation of
how you get these people and how you get
them out of the tunnels and they're
hiding literally in hospitals and using
civilians as human Shields that's a
whole another conversation but you need
to eradicate these people the point is
that number one Hamas will need to be
destroyed but number two how do you
rebuild Gaza after this